[Music]
lines continue to be crossed in this
conflict Israel targeted a car at a
funeral of a senior Hezbollah field
commander killed a day before in an
apparent Israeli drone strike there were
casualties but the crowd was
defiant hours earlier a targeted Israeli
strike hit a car killing three members
of the Lebanese armed group in a
Southern Village 10 km from the
battlefield along the border and a few
kilometers from a similar attack on wisl
tail he was the highest ranking member
of Hezbollah kild since the group opened
a front to help relieve pressure on its
Ally Hamas in Gaza toil was killed a
week after hamas's number two Salah Al
aruri was assassinated in Hezbollah
stronghold in Beirut Israel is trying as
much as I can to provoke hasah into a
confrontation but um once Israel
carries out another strike like in the
capital I think that's when we can say
that hb's policy of deterrence has
failed and that it deterence is indeed
eroding Hezbollah has retaliated to the
killings it used armed drones to attack
an Israeli Army based in safad some 12
km from the border the deepest strike
inside Israel since confrontations began
in October days earlier it targeted an
air traffic control base Israel says the
strikes caused minor damage but the near
daily attacks by Hezbollah have forced
tens of thousands of Israelis from their
homes Israel wants security restored and
is threatening to expand the war unless
that happens Hezbollah is promising to
fight back without restraint if Israel
launches an allout War but its Secretary
General Hassan nasah didn't commit to a
major escalation he hinted that
Hezbollah would be open to negotiations
with Israel on clarifying the borderline
with Lebanon the US has been trying to
work on a long-term border agreement to
reduce tensions but Hezbollah says there
will be no discussions until Israel
stops its
aggression Israel has lost hope in Gaza
and in Lebanon and that is why the
foreign delegates are coming to Lebanon
to try to start negotiations on what
happens after the
war despite the attacks Hezbollah went
ahead with burying its Commander so far
the group through its words and actions
has signaled it wants to avoid a wider
War while Israel escalates and appears
to be testing that position zenah
aljazera Southern
Lebanon make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer